yesterday we talked about the viral
Instagram pose that a straight to come
to a fans wedding well now that fan has
fest up that he faked the whole thing
yeah there was a lot of skepticism
around this as we mentioned yesterday
and this is what it was so an Instagram
account called Drake wedding hosted this
reported DM conversation we asked Drake
what it would take to perform at his
wedding as a surprise to his fiance
yeah the convo then shows Drake
responding saying it would take 1
million likes and hundred thousand
followers well the Drake wedding account
surpassed that goal online day it had
gotten a lot of attention yeah then the
fan appeared on Roz's radio show
yesterday the rosin mocha show and
assured it was real well the attention
made the kid crack
he sent a DM apology to Drake and Drake
exposed the lie on his Instagram yeah
the fan wrote to Drake sorry it blew up
like this I'm a 16 year old kid from
Sanford San Antonio I never meant it to
be like this huge fan of you you can
have my account if you want I don't know
what to do it actually wasn't even at
the 16 year old kid who called in to the
rosin mocha show yesterday he got his
older friend from Xbox so the amount on
Xbox who has a deeper voice to call in
and pretend to be the fan who put out
the wedding offer so here's the 16 year
old on the phone with rosin mochas
producer Morris Sherman today and then
we started it because I I think you
traffic design and I could also do video
editing so I just I put it together a
new drink with most famous person in the
world I mean people would have emphysema
or like not empathy but they would want
rate to perform at their wedding so they
want to yeah I knew it was gonna go
viral so then that's why I did it I
never thought I'd get for this extent to
where I would have my friends on a radio
show across all of Canada it's the same
he's getting married and he met his
girlfriend on a clock are you at all
sorry for what happened do you want to
apologize to the people that believed in
this yes almost [ __ ] rate because
Drake I expected to have all these
articles like complex and others
and all these other big media companies
so I expected to get to this extent I
with causing problems for drink I felt
like solving problems and I was wearing
it today I just decided to do the mmm
and think screenshot answered on the
story
I'm sorry taller people believe in it
and generally wanted me to do it I just
it was more of a joke at first now he
does say he's like super story so you
did also post on the Instagram historia
con that account you posted this thing
it says don't say Alec it's not a loss
this is the biggest win of my life so
it's not completely certainly he got a
lot of attention for this Mikey says
this kid is a genius
it's about lot of ourselves he needs to
be an agent he needs to be doing
marketing or something my eyes I kind of
suspected it when Drake didn't say
anything about it before now definitely
just there's no doubt that kid is all
about the gram and makes his dad a
feeling this was fake he says I feel
like drink needs to actually perform at
a wedding that's exactly what I was
about to say I'm like now he just needs
to find a couple and go to their wedding
and just report that Belle says I didn't
even know about this but nope not
surprised at all people fake them all
the time surprised mostly that I got
that much attention but yeah because you
had like this good the video the
screenshot and everything but let's
think it's like it's a 16 year old like
you kind of do stuff like this think we
all did stuff this is a teenager just
now like the tools that you have to pull
pranks like it's not just like like
prank calling people you can do this
whole social media thing so I don't have
necessary sympathy for him but you've
got like we all did stupid stuff as a
kid but there's just the tools do you
have your further you could tell how
frightened he was to have his friend his
xbox but yeah I figured that party go on
and do a video in the gear we get my
feeling how do I cover this up he was he
was probably panicking at that point she
was definitely trying to cover it up
well poor kid I go back poor kid he's
fine I wonder if that Xbox friend is his
friend anymore then will they have this
whole plan there's only yesterday I know
he's probably not talking him anymore